[Música]
revista de prensa en directo américa de
france 24 rosa pérez más de eeuu que nos
trae hoy me imagino que la compra de
twitter la reacción por este pacto de el
mox con la red social no 44.000 millones
de dólares quisiéramos tener se sea a mí
no de esos 44
acs raúl con eso nos conformaríamos
bastante bueno buenos días antes que
todo y exactamente no porque esta
noticia de que twitter aceptó la oferta
de adquisición de hilo en más que el
hombre más rico del mundo recordemos
para hacerse con la plataforma abre
portadas internacionales empezamos con
el globo de brasil que titula más compra
twitter y genera dudas sobre la acción
contra las noticias falsas bien
insistir en que técnicamente todavía no
se ha materializado la compra como
seguro profundizarán con nuestra
compañera especialista en economía
daniela blandón todavía hay detalles
técnicos y sobre todo regulatorios por
resolver pero aún así se espera que esta
compra se formaliza y ya finalmente pues
a medio plazo a lo largo de este año por
otro lado the gardian dice 44 mil
millones de dólares más gana la batalla
para hacerse con twitter por otro lado
wall street journal titula más que logra
un acuerdo para comprar twitter y por
otro lado el 'washington post' que
recordemos es propiedad propiedad de
jeff bezos quien también fue en 2017 el
hombre más rico del mundo según la lista
de la revista forbes titula 44 mil
millones de dólares- ponen a twitter
bajo control de masca así es rosa
continuamos con un análisis que hacen de
este pacto de compra el medio económico
bloomberg y el tecnológico wire exacto
porque bloomberg dice que bueno
recordemos que más una de las razones
que alegó para hacer esta propuesta de
compra es que twitter es lo más parecido
que tenemos a una plaza pública digital
donde dijo se debaten los temas claves
para el futuro de la humanidad y
recuerda este medio económico que una de
las propuestas de más es llegamos
flexibilizar la moderación de contenidos
para digamos
hasta los límites de la libertad de
expresión en cada país algo que ya
comentamos aquí y que vuelve a poner en
el debate en el centro del debate pues
todo el tema no de la regulación del
discurso del odio en las redes sociales
así es y cambiamos ahora el tema rosa
vamos a repasar unos mayores retos que
afronta la sociedad francesa y el manuel
macro no como el nuevo presidente
recordemos que ganó la segunda vuelta de
las presidenciales el día domingo el
aumento de la extrema derecha si lo
aborda flip marjal en el new york times
y el país en su editorial
eso es empecemos a por el 'new york
times' donde este profesor de la
university college de londres dice que
en francia ya vuelve a respirar
tranquila después de haber descartado el
hecho de que una presidenta de extrema
derecha llegará al elíseo pero dice es
prematuro celebrar dice la democracia
francesa nunca ha estado en peor estado
de salud y comparan los resultados de
este domingo
recordemos donde macro no obtuvo el 58
por 5 por ciento de los apoyos al frente
al 41,5 depende en el marco de un 28 de
abstención con los resultados de 2002
cuando jacques chirac fue reelegido con
un 82 por ciento de los apoyos frente al
padre de marina le pen y jean-marie le
pen dice que esta vez nos sorprendió que
marine lepén la candidata de agrupación
nacional de extrema derecha volviera a
pasar a la segunda vuelta que desde 2017
macrón ha perdido una oportunidad para
digamos
resolver las fracturas de la sociedad
francesa dice sus cinco años de mandato
han estado marcados por el desprecio a
la fiscalización democrática la
condescendencia por los pobres y la
crueldad hacia los migrantes dice que
los chalecos amarillos fueron una
muestra de la profundidad de la
inquietud en el país y dice lejos de ser
una democracia modelo francia es un país
que no se siente cómodo con el
pluralismo el multiculturalismo y el
liberalismo político una condición
revelada por el constante ascenso de la
extrema derecha por otro lado el país en
su editorial en el mismo sentido dice
que si bien macro reconoció que muchos
de los apoyos que recibió este domingo
no fueron por estar de acuerdo con sus
políticas y su programa sino para frenar
a la extrema derecha dice ninguna
democracia puede sobrevivir bajo esa
lógica defensiva de resistencia y que el
ejecutivo francés debe responder al
descontento de las mayorías sociales con
políticas democráticas atrevidas pero es
que raúl en ese sentido destacar que
para muchos fue un rayo de esperanza esa
propuesta de macrón en campaña de
digamos pues matizar esa reforma de las
pensiones pero sin embargo el brunello
bruno le maire el ministro de economía
francés y ha dicho que no descarta
incluso utilizar el artículo 49.3 de la
constitución francesa para pasar esta
reforma un artículo pues muy
controvertido porque a la práctica
permite al gobierno validar un texto
legislativo sin voto en el parlamento
vamos ahora a hablar de izquierda
ucrania nuevamente vamos con lee kiefer
post que resalta lo que dijo el ministro
y sobre el ruso serguéi lávrov que esto
está a punto digamos
de una tercera guerra mundial qué tan
cierto son estas palabras y que titula y
que dice el quiet post pues esperemos
que ésta sea pues una declaración un
poco disuasoria más que nada de cara a
esta pues a la reunión que está teniendo
lugar en alemania donde más de 40 países
pues a debate en el cómo apoyar con más
armamento a ucrania entre otras cosas y
queríamos terminar con el moscú time que
muestra imágenes de la celebración de la
pascua ortodoxa en rusia en moscú
particularmente donde se puede ver
cierta simbología bélica particularmente
está zeta de apoyo a las tropas rusas y
es que recordemos como ya hablamos aquí
que el líder de la iglesia ortodoxa rusa
el patriarca kiril defendió haber
abiertamente la invasión rusa de ucrania
incluso la calificó de guerra santa
gracias.rosa por toda la información por
el esta revista de prensa del diario nos
vemos mañana con más pasamos a saludar a
nuestro primer invitado al día